hello and welcome to maths my file my
name is dr. Omar Malek and I am the
creator of math simplified I've been
creating educational medical and biology
videos since the last five years on
YouTube every video I post requires
hours of research scripting animating
and voiceovers which are all done by me
without any outsourcing with your
support I will be able to expand this
project and hire script writers
animators and social media managers and
probably rent a workspace or studio
which will help us to improve the
quality and quantity of our content
creating quality content takes time and
effort each month and by having a little
financial stability it will allow me to
dedicate more time and energy to the
content to make it the best that it can
be plus plus you will also be getting
all the flash cards lecture handouts and
all the mnemonic cards from methanol if
I'd now you might have a few questions
on how this membership things work so
let me explain that for you a lot of
people have requested me for written
material from educational videos so here
we are we have come up with lecture
handouts from our videos and flashcards
and also a mnemonic cards so how this
thing works is that we have three tiers
with different rewards tier number one
for those who just want to support my
simplified and in return they get access
to my patreon only feed where I share
early notifications behind the scenes of
these videos and other cool images tier
number two is where things get serious
you get access to all the lecture
handouts from all of our videos and
these lectures and outs are simple easy
to read and best use to just before an
exam to help you remember the most
important stuff from that topics plus
you also get 20% discount on our
merchandise store on teespring comm in
Tier three you also get access to flash
cards and mnemonic cards from all of our
videos these cards highlight the most
important stuff that you need to
remember and the mnemonic cards help you
to remember the difficult to memorize
topics plus you also get all the rewards
from the previous tiers and you also get
to connect to me personally all social
media
you